his mom has sent me so many wedding  books on it  et chatted with Jojo Fletcher and Jordan  Rogers at the iHeartRadio Music Festival  in Vegas Friday where they dished on  their wedding planning process we've  been talking about it we don't even know  like the first steps of what to do like  where are we gonna do it it's where and  then it's I think it's one we don't know  a lot of planning we're enjoying being  together now so we'll bachelor nation  see the pair walk down the aisle in a  televised wedding special I think it's  definitely a question but like right now  we're just really enjoying being  together and you know it's fine that we  got to be together on the show but we  haven't really like dated dated outside  of the show and so this has been such a  fun time to like move into our first  home together to go on date exploring  our area of Dallas that we're now the  restaurants that we live that a lot of  good ones but we're definitely not  against it